of one of the most  hey guys and a very warm welcome to  simply learns youtube channel today  we'll be taking you through an in-depth  tutorial on php in this tutorial we'll  cover all the basics of one of the most  popular server-side scripting languages  that is php  according to researchers around 80  percent of the total websites present  out there use php in one way or another  so it's possible that if you are going  through 100 websites in a week then 80  of them are using php  php stands for hyper text preprocessor  and is an open source server side  scripting language mainly used to create  the back end of dynamic websites and web  applications  this tutorial will let you understand